vamos a hacer una síntesis de todo lo
que hemos visto hasta ahora para darnos
un muy buen panorama sobre todo lo que
tiene que ver con células animales y
vegetales y justamente del lado
izquierdo
tengo dibujada una célula animal muy
bien mientras que del lado derecho tengo
dibujada una célula vegetal muy bien
tengo una célula vegetal así que
empecemos con lo que está afuera de la
célula verdad justamente tenemos la
matriz strasse extracelular verdad y que
está formada verdad de un montón de
fibras y muchas otras cosas que nos
ayudan a mantener a las células en su
sitio verdad y permite digamos a las
células relacionarse verdad de hecho
puede incluso ayudarnos a detectar
cierto tipo de señales que provienen de
otras células verdad entonces todo esto
es la matriz extra
celular muy bien y cuando pensamos a la
matriz extracelular para células
vegetales verdad hay hay varios
componentes relacionados con la pared
celular verdad y este es una de las
principales diferencias verdad es quizás
la diferencia más importante entre
células animales y vegetales verdad
entonces aquí tenemos justamente la
pared celular
celular
y bueno claramente las células animales
no tienen pared celular verdad así que
si ahora nos vamos digamos un nivel más
abajo verdad bueno en ambos casos nos
encontramos con esta esta membrana
plasmática verdad que de hecho hemos
nombrado nosotros como membrana celular
verdad
en ambos casos tenemos la membrana
celular verdad que estoy remarcando con
amarillo ahora bien en este en este tipo
de espacio es verdad podemos encontrar
digamos túneles entre células vecinas
muy bien entonces por ejemplo en el caso
de las células vegetales e incluso aquí
puede verse mucho más claro voy a
hacerlo
verdad en las células vegetales por
ejemplo podemos encontrar este tipo de
túneles y que de hecho los estudiamos en
un vídeo anterior verdad de hecho este
tipo de túneles tienen un nombre y son
plasma plasmo des más verdad plasmo
desnudos
estos son los plasmo demos ahora bien
nosotros tenemos un equivalente para las
células animales verdad que nuevamente
son como túneles que conectan digamos
células vecinas verdad entonces aquí
tenemos este tipo de túneles que para el
caso de las células animales se le
conoce como uniones gat
verdad se conocen como uniones gap o
también se les conoce como uniones en
hendidura
entonces los plasmo de smos digamos son
mucho más comunes en muchos más tipos en
varios tipos de células vegetales verdad
son más comunes que lo que son las
uniones en hendidura para las células
animales sin embargo las uniones en
hendidura pueden ser muy importantes en
las células animales en algunas células
animales por ejemplo en las células del
corazón donde debido a estas uniones en
hendidura verdad la señal eléctrica
puede viajar a través del tejido verdad
y que y que nos dice digamos a las
células a las células adyacentes les
dice digamos cuál es el momento de
contraerse y cómo hacerlo de forma
correcta entonces son bastante
importantes las uniones verdad y lo que
tenemos que recordar cuando hablamos de
membrana es verdad que hemos estado
hablando de la membrana celular y en
general de prácticamente todas las
membranas de las células verdad es que
éstas están hechas de una
y capa de fosfolípidos verdad entonces
si por ejemplo nos fijamos en un
cuadrito aquí de membrana verdad si
hacemos un acercamiento lo que vamos a
ver es una bicapa de fosfolípidos verdad
entonces vamos a tener digamos podemos
pensarlo así como dos hileras de
fosfolípidos verdad y éstas están como
digamos hechas de dos cosas tenemos unas
cabezas que tienen la propiedad de ser
hidrofílicas verdad y tenemos colas que
tienen la propiedad de ser hidrofóbicas
verdad y esto sí digamos se extiende en
ambas direcciones muy bien vámonos
ahora digamos a una región interior de
la célula y nosotros aquí podemos
observar el citoesqueleto verdad tenemos
aquí el citoesqueleto el citoesqueleto
está digamos conformado por micro
filamentos que estoy digamos
y remarcando con este color claro
tenemos sí perdón tenemos
microfilamentos verdad
también tenemos microtúbulos tenemos
microtúbulos microtúbulos y de hecho el
citoesqueleto tanto los microfilamentos
como los microtúbulos están presentes
tanto en células vegetales como en
células animales verdad ahora bien
nosotros también podríamos encontrar
filamentos intermedios también forman
parte digamos del sitio esqueleto aunque
sólo es parte del citoesqueleto de la
célula animal muy bien vamos a empezar a
describir ciertas estructuras que están
presentes en la célula animal pero que
no están en la célula vegetal son estas
estructuras y estas estructuras se
llaman centrosomas muy bien éstas como
lo mencioné sólo se encuentran en la
célula animal y juegan digamos un papel
clave en digamos organizar los
microtúbulos verdad y sobre todo
hablaremos de ellos
veamos la mitosis de hecho bueno las
células vegetales también tienen otra
forma de arreglárselas para para
organizar los microtúbulos sobre todo
para el momento de la división celular
verdad pero bueno estos centros o más
solo se encuentran en la célula animal y
un organelos que solo se encuentra en
las células vegetales esta estructura
digamos muy grande que tenemos aquí
digamos de color como
azul y está verdad y que se encuentran
por ejemplo detrás de estas de estos
organelos verdes y esto que tenemos aquí
lo conocemos como vacuola verdad este es
de hecho una vacuola central
central esta es una vacuola central y el
rol digamos importante de las vacuolas
es que pueden almacenar fluido verdad
pueden incluso almacenar enzimas o
pueden ser incluso un lugar para los
desperdicios verdad y resulta que aunque
son muy comunes en las células vegetales
pueden tener roles muy distintos
dependiendo del tipo de célula en
particular por ejemplo pueden ayudar a
dar estructura a la célula verdad y
quiero quiero seguir enfatizando esto
verdad que de hecho lo he mencionado
mucho en otros vídeos verdad y cuando
vemos todos estos organelos digamos en
imágenes o en diagramas bueno en
realidad podría uno pensar que conocemos
muy bien sus funciones pero pero casi
todos estos organelos y de hecho
podríamos decir que toda la célula en sí
es
un área activa de hecho es un área muy
activa de investigación verdad y en los
próximos días en las próximas décadas
vamos a descubrir muchas más cosas de
estos organelos y digamos también de las
formas en las que detectan señales entre
ellas verdad podemos vamos a poder
entender mucho mejor las interacciones
que tienen verdad digamos los organelos
entre ellos así como cuál sería su
comportamiento bajo circunstancias
diversas verdad así que realmente
estamos comenzando digamos a entender
qué es lo que hay en la célula y apenas
realmente tenemos una idea de lo que
hacen los organelos pero bueno volviendo
al tema de las células verdad teníamos
teníamos la vacuola en la célula vegetal
y aunque hay vacuolas en algunas células
animales por ejemplo aquí tenemos una
una vacuola en nuestra célula animal
verdad en realidad no tenemos vacuolas
en todas las células animales en
realidad digamos el mejor análogo que
tenemos para las vacunas para las
células animales son estas estructuras
digamos que aquí pinte con color naranja
esto de aquí es un
zuma
lisosomas verdad y pueden verse como
digamos el depósito de los desperdicios
en donde hay un montón de enzimas aquí
adentro verdad que para que puedan
hacerse cargo de cualquier cosa que
entre y puedan deshacer la verdad de
hecho tienen un ph más bajo para que así
las cosas se puedan deshacer y luego
digamos las piezas que quedan puedan
puedan reciclarse muy bien y ya que
estamos hablando del metabolismo celular
hablemos ahora de las peroxisomas verdad
entonces son estas estructuras verdes
que tenemos por aquí verdad las
peroxisomas se encuentran tanto en
células animales como en células
vegetales así que digamos estos de aquí
son peroxisomas pero sí
o más
mas peroxisomas
y de hecho adoptan este nombre de verdad
porque cuando cuando los estaban
estudiando dijeron hey mira parece ser
que aquí hay reacciones de oxidación
verdad y parece que el producto final es
peróxido de hidrógeno ahora bien en
realidad los los peroxisomas todavía se
están tratando de investigar sobre todo
cuáles son sus funciones principales
pero sabemos que son muy importantes
para poder cortar largas cadenas de
ácidos grasos y que puedan ser útiles en
otras partes de la célula muy bien ahora
vamos a retomar un poco las diferencias
que hay entre digamos célula animal y
célula vegetal por ejemplo aquí podemos
encontrar estos personajes en la célula
vegetal que son fundamentales verdad
esto es fundamental para el
funcionamiento de la célula vegetal y
esto es de aquí son los cloroplastos
cloro platos bien aquí tenemos los
cloroplastos y es en los cloroplastos
donde se realiza la fotosíntesis ok
éstos sólo se encuentran en la célula
vegetal y digamos en la fotosíntesis es
el proceso mediante el cual genera su
propio alimento gracias a la energía de
la luz ahora bien si pensamos en digamos
las la fábrica de atp es de la célula
justamente estamos hablando de las
mitocondrias verdad estamos hablando de
las mitocondrias las mitocondrias se
encuentran tanto en células animales
como en células vegetales verdad ahora
bien otra cosa que podemos encontrar en
ambas células es el aparato de golgi
aquí tenemos el aparato de golgi tanto
en célula animal como en célula vegetal
y es aquí en donde se empaquetan digamos
las proteínas para su uso ya sea dentro
o fuera de la célula ahora bien también
tenemos este extra
la imagen está la verdad que está como
que parece muy enredada tiene muchos
pliegues verdad y este es el retículo
endoplasmático que también se encuentra
en ambas células y en el retículo
endoplasmático grueso se encuentran los
ribosomas que son estas bolitas
amarillas que pintado verdad y se
encuentran unidos a la membrana verdad
mientras que en el retículo
endoplasmático liso no encontramos estos
ribosomas muy bien entonces es en el
retículo endoplasmático donde se
elaboran las proteínas e incluso pueden
elaborarse algunos lípidos muy bien
ahora aquí en digamos en este color azul
hito verdad podemos encontrar la
membrana nuclear y de hecho es la
membrana nuclear interna verdad porque
la externa es contigua al retículo
endoplasmático verdad dentro de la
membrana nuclear encontramos el adn
encontramos el adn verdad y él está en
una forma de cromatina muy bien de hecho
en estas regiones más densas del del adn
verdad es lo que conocemos como núcleo
lo verdad es la zona más densa y que de
hecho se puede observar en un
microscopio y estas zonas se asocia con
el área a rn ribosomal muy bien y
hablando de ribosomas tenemos ribosomas
libres verdad a lo largo digamos del
citoplasma a lo largo y ancho de todo el
citoplasma celular y bueno
esto que acabamos de ver aquí es en
realidad un panorama muy general de lo
que son las células eucariontes de hecho
en particular estamos hablando de
células animales y vegetales pero espero
que esto te haya mostrado las
diferencias principales entre estos dos
tipos de células